hello everyone and welcome to the tie
breaks of the World Chess Championship
match the after 14 games of classical
chess we have a tie and now we have to
play Four rapid games it's 25 minutes uh
plus 10 seconds per player and four
games will be played if that is the draw
then we're going to Blitz Games and then
if the blitz games are drawn then we go
into sudden death This is the first game
of the Rapids ding has the white pieces
uh let's see what happened in this one
so I think with the white pieces opens
with D4 we have Knight to F6 uh Knight
to F3 D5 and now Pawn to C3 a very rare
continuation but uh as you probably
already have suspected it has been
played by a very strong player none
other than his second rihad Rapport so
let's see what they prepared Pawn to C5
with the captors and C5 Ponte E6 and now
Bishop to E3 ding says although usually
you can never keep your Pawn when you
capture it but this is now rapid chess
uh it's up to you to figure out how to
properly capture it back bishop t7 and
now we have Pawn to G3 there are some
other top tier games that reach this
position like Vladimir kramnik had it
against body's gelf fund last year but
the game that we are focusing on is a
rapport versus Samuel Shanklin from 2019
and here we have Knight to C6 and with
this move nepo deviates from all of
those games and it is now as of move 6
that we have a completely new game so
dingo's Bishop G2 we have castles and
now Pawn to B4 just keeps that pawn
nicely defended and now well A4 B5 is
coming and uh what does nepo have to
show for his um position being down upon
he goes Knight to G4 says that the
bishop does not belong there let's go
after it with Bishop to D4 and now Queen
to C7 uh if you're wondering why not
just E5 isn't this just winning for
black looks really spectacular the
problem is H3 and now after he captures
on the four end captures here thus the
semi-open file for white is a bit too
much for example you capture here now
even B5 challenges the night after the
night moves you're gonna capture on C3
then the win comes to D3 goes after the
H7 Pawn looks very scary so that's why
uh Queen to C7 Bayan and now we have
castles biting and now the ding Castle
young just gave him a look and said all
right but now you kind of won't have the
semi-openh file and he does go for it
Ponte E5
uh we have H3 now ding challenges the
Knight here he captures on D4 H Captain
G for D captures on C3 and now Knight
captures on C3 the problem is if you
play B5 there's the in-between Bishop to
F6 move and this just looks very ugly
now if B capture respond to C2 attacks
the queen and the Rook um on A1 so
instead after d captures and C3 just
Knight captures and now Knight captures
on B4 here uh we have Pawn to A3 tracing
away the Knight and now not um doing
anything weird like Queen captures on C5
looks great uh for you to trade the nice
the problem is there's Knights the A4
attacks the queen next move you capture
the Knight and the Knight here is
defended so this would be a blunder for
black so that's why nepo just puts the
bishop on this diagonal where it belongs
Rook to C1 Bishop captures and C3 Rook
captures and not just Knight back to C6
and we have this position equal material
uh let's see uh how they continue and
now ding has to decide does he Wanna
Give up the G4 Pawn does he want to
capture on D5 does he want to play
something weird like Quinta A4 to guard
the G4 Pawn maybe focus on D5 as a
long-term weakness well after some
considering ding does go for Queen
captures on D5 even though Queen to A4
is the top engine move
adding decides for a practical practical
game queen that D5 will offer him better
chances uh Bishop countress on G4 and
now uh Knights the G5 the situation the
clock is 17 minutes for Ding and 20
minutes for nepo and you can see now
that uh weird stuff is happening here
um uh again like in the previous game
ding puts an item G5 and now the queen
can come to D3 to E4 threatened that
Checkmate for example if you play
something like Rook 888 just ignore
White Queen to D3 threatens Checkmate
now you could play G6 but then Knight
comes to E4 and you're hoping to get the
Knight to D6 but you will stop it with
something like Queen to E5 and now after
now of course you cannot move because
the E2 Pawn would hang after E3 you will
stop Knight D6 with Bishop to F5 and
this is maybe the safest way to go about
this for black but H sequence played
right away and nothing says all right
Knight to E4 you could also try an
in-between move
uh with Queen the E4 to sort of trade
like this but the thing feels that it's
much more important to bring the Knight
to D6 so Rook 888 and now Ponte E3 ding
feels that you don't need to give
anything you are bringing your knight to
D6 uh e rookie 5 and now Queen to D2 We
have Rook to d8 the continuing
harassment on dings Queen Knights the D6
now and if you look at the position now
ding's position is absolutely
spectacular and how is nipple to defend
the B7 Pawn that uh Pawn will be under
attack but nipple finds a way he just
plays Rook to H5 absolutely brilliant uh
just uh shows how much uh uh King side
weaknesses that Ding has and now imagine
if this Knight comes to F3 if this
Knight lands on F3 with check it's game
over uh and here a thing is actually
winning but it's really hard to see in a
classical game you have to play Queen to
C2 followed by Queen to B3 and go after
the B7 Pawn ding does that just not with
the queen ding plays Rook to B1 but the
problem is now that he will not have
this uh F4 when the time comes the
problem is if you play Queen to C2 and
now never plays Knight E5 you have F4
because the bishop and The Rook are
guarding the F3 Square however here
after Rook to B1 The Rook will not help
with the support of the F3 square and
now nepo just goes 95 and he says uh
feel free to capture on B7 and if ding
does this it's game over just Knight F3
check and doesn't matter what you do you
are getting checkmated on H1 you can
even capture Black's Queen Rook to H1
will be Checkmate so after 95 we have E4
this is how ding defends the F3 square
but it still gives nepo a bit too much
he plays Pawn to B6 like in the previous
game where ding played Pawn to B6 here
B6 is the absolute strongest move for
nipple and now the problem is how do you
defend uh you could try something like
F4 but then Knight to F3 check look at
this bishop captures and F3 now Rook
captures on C5 and after real characters
on C5 and queen captures you will play
Queen to F2 as uh the black white King
was in check Queen captures an F2 with
checking captures Bishop captures and F3
and now E5 you defend your knight let's
say Bishop to G4 and the game continues
with nepo being up a pawn so although
very nice it still leaves nepo in a
better position so ding goes for the
absolute main line of the position and
that is C captures on B4 he opens attack
on nipples Queen but nipple just plays
eight captures on B6 and he gives up his
Queen but again if the Rook leaves
control of the F3 Square it's once again
game overnight F3 check if you capture
you just get checkmated so you have to
move the king and then comes Knight
captures with check King T1 even Rook
captures on these six guards the Knight
so absolutely crushing uh black is um uh
upper full night of course you just
resigned this so ding plays Knights the
B5 absolute strongest move and look at
this now black queen is hanging White
Queen is hanging everything is hanging
is this a World Chess Championship Game
yes it is and while Nepal could decide
something like Queen to E7 and maybe he
should have he was much better on time
here he decides to trade he plays Rook
captures on D2 Knight captures on C7 and
now Bishop to H3 it seems like the
critical line uh with Knight to the D3
to go after the F2 pawn and now after
Rook to F1 defending this Pawn just to
Rook the C5 and it looks like it's not
easy for white to find moves maybe this
was the way to go of course white has
Knight to D5 The Rook is nicely defended
you will never capture of course give
black a pass Pawn uh so it's uh you know
definitely one of the possibilities but
he played Bishop to H3 and now we have
Bishop captures Rook captures King to G2
and now just to Rook back the H5 but the
dink counters back with Rook to B5 now
you cannot move the Knight
and uh while G6 is definitely an option
uh it looks very scary look at this
Knight the D5 now coming for Knight to
F6 check and now look at this Knight the
G4 guards this square and threatens Rook
captures on F2 King F3 and now what
would be possible is this uh Knight
sacrifice and then just a nice draw by
repetition of course you can't go here
because of Checkmate have to play King
H3 and then we would probably have a
nice draw by repetition but instead Rook
the D1 was played now comes Knight to D5
and Rook D to H1 this is how Nepal goes
for ding's King but of course now of
course you can see that there is no
other conclusion to this game other than
Knights the E7 check King to H7 and The
Rook captures on E5 this is how ding
goes for it because now if nipple
captures he also loses The Rook on H1 so
a repetition is a match here Rook
advantage to check King to G1 rookies
one checking to G2 and he was in this
position on move 35 that nipple and ding
agreed to a draw as there is nothing
more to be done here the problem is if
you go to F3 then nipple can capture
because now The Rook is no longer
hanging and of course ding cannot afford
that so he of course settles for
repetition so game one of the Rapids
ends in a draw next game nipple has the
white pieces we'll see what happens will
we have a new world champion in Rapid or
will it have to be decided in Blitz uh
stay tuned uh and you know find out so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
when I say soon I I definitely mean soon
see you soon